hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir freunde und zwar habe ich
hier schon einige sachen vorbereitet und
ihr seht es auch bereits eingeblendet
ich mache heute eine pizza backen oder
nein über den supermarkt und ich habe
mir dort im weitzel schirmer gekauft ich
habe mir zucker gekauft ich habe mir
eine tomatensoße gekauft ich habe mir
auch ananas und schinken hat er von euch
hinten ist fertig gegessen ich wollte so
eine grüne pizza hawaii machen und jetzt
ist ja so zwei scheiben schinken
das war geiler 8
wir haben hier noch mozzarella krise ich
habe noch zeit und liebe hat diese pause
jetzt man wasser hier für die plätze
hinter der kamera und julia haben mal
wieder ein rezept zwar vorbereitet noch
eröffnet das heißt wenn ich komplett
verkaufen sollte kann sich noch
eingreifen ich würde sagen ich fange
jetzt allerdings erstmal an den teils
machen weil ich habe mir natürlich nicht
so herzig zeit gekauft natürlich zu
einfach gewesen der käse kommt auf jeden
fall drauf bevor wir das einen ofen
schieben mit tomatensoße kommen auch
erst mal drauf der datei kann ich es ja
damals genauso der schinken auch das
heißt ja eigentlich pizza hawaii freunde
pizza hawaii
ich würde sagen ich sage jetzt
allerdings erstmal mit dem teig und zwar
habe ich extra pakete gekauft weil ich
weiß auch von mir dabei am früher dass
man in heimen was guckst du so oder mehr
zwei sondern drei minister hahn ich
arbeite ja mit mir auf jeden fall diesen
hilfe der kommt auf jeden fall hier rein
dann als nächstes würde ich sagen muss
dann ein bisschen wasser ja sager die
hilfe stimmte wieder nicht immer da
müssen wir schauen wie man sich jetzt zu
wissen daraus macht sich stinkt apropos
tiefkühlpizza viele leute denkbar
wasserpegel hast du das auch mal was
anderes verfahren heute wollte ich habe
ja schon eine breite palette von einer
weiterhin sehr geil fand und wer setzt
es ein meeting und haben beschlossen
dass wir eine zweite mitzumachen werden
das heißt aber an der stelle dass ich
auf euch angewiesen bin also was ist ihr
selbst am liebsten für eine pizza oder
was könnt ihr euch kurz vorstellen also
schreibt das aber gerne in die
kommentare und ich würde sagen dass wir
jetzt mal weitermachen hier mit diesem
team bisher schon echt cool ist ein
beschissener kameramann dafür machen wir
jetzt weiter die pizza teig hier als
erstes kommt er allerdings oder ein
drittes mittlerweile wieder mehr wasser
mischen
auch wenn jetzt kommt da noch ein
bisschen mehr räume weil das ganze muss
natürlich auch in der division systems
haben das ist natürlich hier keine
flüssigkeit oder irgendwie so das würde
sagen was mich dann ein bisschen helfen
hier wie viel mehr würdest du dir ein
packendes 2000 jahre später ich vor
sagen wir mal was sagen die menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich groß da das ganze
allerdings nicht nur so nach mil und in
häfen gut schmecken soll habe ich ja
noch ein bisschen zucker vorbereitet das
heißt da gehe ich jetzt mal ganz kurz
hier mit einem löffel rainer seiner für
zucker würde ich sagen aber auch noch
rein
so jetzt haben wir das hier noch mal ein
bisschen zeit seiner videos ganz in sich
ist so sieht das ganze jetzt
mittlerweile aus möbeln kannst das auch
mal film hier vorne genau zu sein das
heißt das jetzt ganz nah dran bist und
ich glaube es wird eine leistung von 1
ich glaube das wird noch kommen
das ist unmenschlich vielmehr das waren
locker 250 familie ist aber auch hier
gut wenn man auch weiter ein bisschen
pizzateig ist echt ein bisschen härter
juli das ist jetzt einfach noch mehr
dann oft pizza bäcker kannst du mir
helfen da nicht mal so schlecht freunde
ehrlich wieso freunde ich das allein
daran will ich mal probieren wir vorne
das heißt sie sind auf jeden fall
gespannt auf deinem ersten geschmacks
ist julia will jetzt hier unbedingt
diesen tag durchkneten keine ahnung
warum
die männerwelt hinter was das weingut
aufsetzen indischen bucks mit
ich würde sagen mit großen haken wir
auch betriebsart und ober unterhitze und
aufgefordert das singen wie sie als den
raab oder switch den nichts getan und
dahinter nun zum ersten mal diesen teig
in der hand freunde der ist aber geld
habt kein selbstgänger wird ihr kind ja
herr der clip viel zu groß oder wie ihr
freund ich lasse so ein film an den
vorher lag ja ich glaube einige wochen
geheimpapier du sie dabei den teig
erdbeer oder weniger fertig gemacht
haben will ich sagen ich lasse den jetzt
einfach mal aufs blech puzzle zusammen
also ich finde ganz im ernst so schlimm
sieht es nicht aus jetzt wo ich das habe
ich hier noch immer scheint in der tat
also wenn mit 70 auf dem backwerk drauf
liegen das heißt sie war schon jetzt
schon mal die hände und als nächstes
kommen wie das format und so sind zum
teil zum käse ich warte nun hier die
pizza das schön auf dem bachbett liegen
haben ist der nächste schritt natürlich
dass wir es mit tomatensoße darauf
klatschen das heißt ich kann da schon
drauf hmm freunde hier kommt die schöne
tomatensoße drauf ich bin ich so kaka
aus dafür dass ich selbst gemacht hat
natürlich erst einmal die tomatensoße
selber machen können und den käse selbst
etwas milch und so ein scheiß aber
wir sind ja nicht beim
qualitätsfernsehen tomatensoße drauf
freuen
das heißt es nochmal hier die lese er ja
erst als käse armee natürlich schön
mozzarella käse ausgewählt das heißt den
sträucher jetzt richtig schön drüber
sondern das als pizzabäcker hat wirklich
macht also der krise ist jetzt auf jeden
fall auch darauf freue ich werde mir das
kannst du auch heiße sache
das heißt wir kommen jetzt endlich mal
zudem bleibt das heißt hier die an das
schöne australischen soll hier die
andere das können wir jetzt auch noch so
entspannen sie ihnen kurz durchschneiden
in so ein paar gleich prof stückchen
hier die kommen dann natürlich auch noch
weiter nachdem seine sache auch insider
sagt man okay ist geil ist geil fruchtig
das sind zum beispiel ich da so etwas
sagen aber an zusagen auch richtig geil
jetzt auf jeden fall noch wir stinken
hier hinter den kulissen wurde gerade
schon gedacht weil angeblich die hilfe
menge die ich eigentlich nicht zu viel
wir werden mal sehen wie das ganze dann
gleich anrufen ausschaut leider ist
jetzt nicht so viel schinken hier mehr
übrig weil wie gesagt einige menschen
hier haben schon gegessen
der öffentliche vortrag freundeskreis
benehmen jetzt diese pizza die jetzt
gerade so aus die haben ganz klar eine
selbst gebacken ist ein verschieben des
anblicks tierreich und zwar schnell um
ein auf die figuren szene halt sagen
waren 14 minuten und dann schauen wir
mal wie es jetzt aussieht das jetzt
hätte ich es drei serien späte lange
zeit gewartet meine damen und herren die
pizza ist fertig
deswegen sei er unser flachen brot so
das ganze sieht aus wie eine pizza aber
es war schon ein bisschen so viel hilfe
bitte sagen die spitze liegende kabel
ich bin sauer weil ich gerade nicht dass
das ding native schmeckt weil dann wäre
das richtige gesagt ich nehme jetzt
einfach mal hier so ein stück und zwar
das landstück und habe sogar schon ein
hinter vorbereitet die pizza isst
hardcourt heiß auf jeden fall besuchte
ein bisschen gerne darüber denn die
teams haben diesen film aussieht freuen
und jetzt kommt der erste biss den ich
dieser kitzler gebe die ich ohne ein
rezept gebacken habe
[Musik]
ich hab's wieder hinbekommen und was
sagt die pizzabäckerin zu der pizza also
wir werden die pizza hier ist auf jeden
fall noch auf essen freunde weil ganz im
ernst es ist echt hardcore geil geworden
diese pizza für filme
da ist ein bisschen da ist die pizza
dies ist echt richtig gut das würdet ihr
der pizza für eine zahl geben zwischen
124 20 danke an der stelle wird das
gebiet ist allerdings auch bei hätten
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat und ich eventuell nochmal
etwas kochen so etwas warten soll ohne
rezept dann schreibe ich nun in die
kommentare schreiben auch in die
kommentare was eure lieblings pizza ist
bzw was ihr gerne auf einer pizza als
topping es sonst gerade aufgefallen ist
diese pizza exakt so schmeckt wie pizza
von pizza hat also wahrscheinlich könnte
demnächst bei anfangen aber dafür das
ist die pizza wirklich ohne rezept
gemacht hat finde ich geht die recht
klar deswegen freunde lasst ein leiter
und wir das glas wasser ziel vom video
das war es jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt jemand den kanal abonnieren
oder hier unten meinen job aus
schenkungen findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent zeit
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]